hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast wound biofilm the
evolving science and clinical management
maíam Bob Witter can all be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab routes comm
leading social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by roche
diagnostics as a global leader in health
care roche diagnostics offers a broad
portfolio of tools that help healthcare
providers and nearly detection
prevention diagnosis and treatment of
diseases they molecular diagnostics
roche is driven by a vision of working
with laboratories like yours to improve
medical value you offer in microbiology
infectious disease oncology and genomics
Roche continues to meet unmet needs
through investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with the goal of supporting your
important role in improving patients
lives to learn more about roche
diagnostics please visit us diagnostics
Roche com thank you before we begin
today's presentation i have a few
announcements to make first of all this
is an interactive event and you are
strongly encouraged to submit questions
and comments during the presentation to
do so click on the green presentation
button and then clean green Q&A button
the lower left of your presentation
window and enter your comment or
question in the green in the Q&A box
that appears on the screen next the
presentation slides will appear in the
slide window you can enlarge the slides
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right of the slide window and
finally if you experience any technical
difficulties with seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button in the upper right of the
presentation window or let us know
what's happening using the qmq a button
in the lower left and we'll resolve the
issue as quickly as possible thank you
now I'd like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Randall Walcott dr. Walcott
is the founder of the Southwest Regional
wound care center in Lubbock Texas wound
care center specializes in biofilm based
wound care the wound care center offers
state-of-the-art technology with
molecular diagnostics and
state-of-the-art alternative medicine
including customized wound topical wound
gels dr. Walcott was passionate about
healing wounds please join me in
welcoming dr. Walcott to today's
presentation I will now turn the
presentation over damn thank you Bob
this is a brand new format for me and so
you know we'll just go with it the thing
I worry about is we might not be able to
connect as well so if you guys have
questions you'll put them out there and
we'll try to answer them as we go this
is about one ball fill my first thing I
have to tell you is I do have a little
conflict of interest on a part equity
owner and a molecular laboratory that
utilizes Roche technology and what we
decided is that even though we can
identify the bacteria that we see in
wins and we can identify a different
microbial reality than we've ever had
before and that's the quote did you see
up there by Erasmus you know in the land
of the blind the one-eyed man is king
well what we realize real quick we were
seeing these bacteria we were
understanding that there were new
species and different groups of bacteria
than we'd ever seen before but what we
realized was more importantly is what we
perceive or how we organize that
information and that's what i was
talking about connecting with you i like
to see if my arguments are penetrating
if they're if they're taking hold and i
won't be able to do that today but when
you look at this and you see two faces
ok that's a data set that's just just
pixels on your screen and you see an
image of two faces but then if we if we
come at this a different direction you
can see a candlestick it's
the same data set we organize it
differently in our brain and we come to
two different conclusions and that leads
us to the elephant in the room which is
biofilm it's neglected in medical
textbooks it's neglected in medical
microbiology in definitely neglected in
clinical medicine I think you're going
to see that we can lay a very good
foundation from the literature that bow
film is not only real because I get that
question all the time but bow film is
important a very important driver in
health care today so whether this is a
four-legged elephant or a six-legged
elephant it is the elephant in the room
so the best way start is what is a bowel
film and way back in nineteen oh it was
back in the 1970s carterton had a
scientific American article how bacteria
stick and that's the first mention of
this community behavior of bacteria that
there's other make mentions but that's
the first organized and credited mention
of model film costerton was invited by
scientific american and this is a
nineteen nineteen ninety nine article
just a review article and its importance
of medicine but this shows you the
timeline of biofilm you have the ability
for biofilm to stick or excuse me for
planktonic bacteria to come in let's use
an arrow on that to come in and actually
attached to a surface attachment is a
very strong molecular signal for that
bacteria to upregulate bottle film
suites of genes within its genome and so
very quickly when we're talking five
minutes or less it it puts out it
secretes extra cited polymeric
substances and thats things like
polymeric sugars proteins extracellular
DNA and it can incorporate
molecules from the from the environment
and it will form this micro colony that
you see here so once in the cells are
dividing they're still active so in a
micro colony you have the biofilm
switching over to model film at the
phenotype switching over to biofilm and
then after a quorum a certain number of
cells as cell density is reached and a
certain number of molecules are put out
into that matrix that signal is strong
enough to cause biofilm to take on a
three-dimensional shape so there's a
heterogeneity or a difference in the
phenotypic expression of the genes in
the top part of the bowel film as well
as in the mid part in the bottom of the
bottle film so there's a lot of science
that goes in that there's thousands of
articles every year that that are
produced on on the molecular level of
what's happening here but in this we're
taking a real high level view right now
at this at this line and basically what
we're saying is is that the bank that
the formation of a mature biofilm
requires a lot of differentiation a lot
of cooperation between not only
individual species but interspecies so
we have to we have say gram negatives
gram positives we have different groups
of bacteria that have to cooperate with
one another that seems to be organized
by the quorum sensing systems that are
there president in the biofilm and at
the end of its once it reaches the
climax community and and it through its
glowing sensing mechanisms it decides
it's not going to get any bigger then it
starts seeing back or propagating into
the environment about seventy percent of
its seating back into the environment is
in packets and those packets are
important clinically and then the other
thirty percent is planktonic back
so these are these cells actually
developed a flagella and all that the
genetic expression or the phenotype of
planktonic bacteria in there they're
released into the environment so that's
Bond film in a nutshell and it's very
important and we're going to take those
concepts and see if we can and here are
some a concert ends ideas on how we
could manage each one of these steps
medically and we'll try to weave some of
those together at the end of the of the
presentation so that's my phone it is
real it's well accepted its vetted in
the community not even i'm going to
guess three months ago at NWO CN i was
attending a lecture and this top
illustration was used to identify what's
happening in the moon bed with bacteria
this is how wounds organize their the
microbes in willing to organize and the
fact is it's not true I mean if you look
in with electron microscope if you look
in with confocal or any other imaging
technology you're not going to see these
fuzzy balls you're not going to see
individual planktonic bacteria residing
on the surfaces contamination or maybe
propagating a little bit and climbing up
on each other but not invading the
surface or even becoming critically
colonized you you really don't see that
kind of behavior well what you see is
more what's in the bottom depiction we
have here this was done by Pig Dirk's at
CBE and basically the bacteria attached
just like the last slide we showed it'll
formula micro call me quickly what
causes what's the trigger for that
attachment micro colony formation we
still don't know that's a good area of
research but it seems like bacteria are
much more successful if they are in a
biofilm phenotype and we'll talk about
that in a second then if they're in the
planktonic bacteria or phenotype inside
a host environment because there's host
immunity the defenses are necessary the
defenses
are only found in the bow filipino time
so once that micro commie forms and it
will form if white blood cells
antibiotics or antibodies or compliment
if those things aren't present then then
that can attach and if the host immunity
is slow then quorum sensing can take
place it places bacteria deep into the
tissue 34 millimeters in a mouse model
it will rise up off the surface again
three four five millimeters with
impregnated with host materials and so
this is what we see microscopically this
said this like I'm saying you can
organize this this data in different
ways and it looks like if we organize
around biofilm we're going to explain
what we see on the wound bed a lot
better so let's just talk about is it
mild film every wound care provider that
I've talked to every scientists it works
with the microbiology of wounds agrees
there's bacteria in a wound so there's
only three things that bacteria can be
doing it can be doing something to help
us like a commensal and the point of
this slide it doesn't illustrate it well
is is that there are commensal systems
for every bacteria committing bacterium
has its commensal system staph
epidermidis has its commensal system
propionibacterium the commensals that
are on our skin that cause us no harm
that keep us free of certain pathogens
have clear crosstalk between certain
cells with certain cytokines and other
chemical mediators so those commensal
systems only exist in the government's
that there are predicated on the cell
lines and and the the immune cells that
are in that host environment when you
break through the skin when you're in
subcutaneous tissue or fat or muscle or
tendon those commensal systems only
exist therefore they're really can't be
a commensal when
well how about contaminants we all know
what contaminants are and like this
little guy right here you know he's not
hurting anybody he's not dividing he's
you know he came in from the environment
and he's just residing on the moon DS
transient that's what we consider a
contaminant is not attached and it's not
doing any harm and that's that can
happen in words this is an acute wound
and that's basically when we looked at
sixteen different acute wounds with
different technologies this is mainly
what we see but the the hallmark of this
is is very low numbers of bacteria if we
if we buy up to this wound and we look
for bacteria we're looking at 10 to the
second ten to the third numbers we're
not looking at 10 to the 7 10 to the 8
10 to the 9th / 5 millimeter biopsy so
acute wounds tend to have what you would
consider contaminant and then bacteria
could do a negative thing and that could
possibly be like this now this is from a
diabetic foot ulcer and it's one of the
moons that we included in our
publication in 2008 and basically I just
want you to look at it these are cops
these up here or Cox I these are rods
and then you've got different sizes
different shapes and so this is truly
polymicrobial now here this is host
extracellular matrix this is host
extracellular matrix just like what
you're seeing up here and it's collagen
so this is only about 10 to 15 microns
thick I don't film does not have to be
thick but these web this Web material
that you see sticking it onto the
surface of the wound that's host
material that's fibrinogen that's been
that's been pulling rise to fibrin and
and it also helps the bacteria stick
little surface so this is a bow film by
anybody's definition and the question
then becomes can that does that cause
infection well yeah it does i mean the
quick answer and this is caution stewart
science article from 99 this there were
other people that talked about bowel
infection but this put it in a pictorial
form and really fleshed it out for me
anyway and basically there is showing
just exactly what we talked about
earlier bacteria find a host environment
a breach in the epithelium over in the
skin or whatever in this case they were
talking about cystic fibrosis but this
works for all chronic infection for all
biofilm infections so the bacteria if
there's any antibodies around it will
kill it if there's any antibodies though
neutralize it complement white blood
cells but if host immunity is slow the
micro colony forms you see the
phenotypic shift from the white
planktonic to the black cobalt them and
I can't stress that enough the this is
one third of the genetic material of the
bacterium it changes in that in that
radical think of it as a caterpillar to
a butterfly so it's quite different
different antibiotic spectrums different
properties then in see the there's one
sensing it rises up off the surface now
the climax community is resistant to
antibodies and antibiotics and white
blood cells but now the bacteria has a
problem okay if it were to attack the
tissue and buy just the tissue like a
like an acute infection like a
planktonic bacteria does it loses its
foothold it loses its attachment to the
host environment so that's that that's
not effective so what it does is it
causes hyper inflammation through
pro-inflammatory cytokines whatever
calls in white blood cells these figures
it agains under MMPs 289 and what you've
got is a is a enflamed area of the host
which is the hallmark of all chronic
infections is it's persistent
inflammation and the inflammation
produces the capillaries to [ __ ] leaking
that's a
copy of inflammation mechanisms are
worked out and plasma leaks out and that
plasma is a continuum nutrient source
for the bottom so I want you to think of
biofilm infections more like a parasitic
infection that can set there and
propagate and release ten twenty thirty
percent of its mass out into the
environment continually day after day
versus an acute infection was just more
predatory which is you know either the
host kills it or it kills the hosting it
it's not as successful in the long term
as a biofilm infection so that model has
been worked out for almost 15 years 16
years now so to put this inspect in
perspective in the winter community
gardener just two years after that
unknowing of mouth film or any of those
principles said let's see what sets a
chronic wound apart chronic wounds the
the wound care provider feels like it's
infected but you know it maybe it
doesn't have the the redness or the
tenderness or the heat or the signs of
celsus like we take a one infection
however what we do see is there's
significant series actually well that's
that plasma we talk about the leaking up
through the bottom to nourish it there's
discoloration of the tissue there's
yellow and black and brown it's not
always the red granular color that you
would think of a healing wound there's
friable titian that just means
dysfunctional so it doesn't have the
right tensile strength or the blood
vessels or a Barrett and you know why
would host healing create those
appearances unless host healing as
usurped by different molecules that
interrupt that host team in cascade and
we'll talk about that in a second
pocketing of tissue is just the bacteria
or rogan down into a surface and that's
a property in biofilm odor human cells
don't produce any volatile molecules so
the owner must be coming from bacteria
and then the big one that's that
most people accept and quote and don't
think anything about is failure to
progress okay the wound is stalled it
doesn't heal right it's chronic what the
definition of a chronic wound is failure
to progress so all of a sudden we have
the same definition for bout them for
secondary signs of infection is the same
thing for a non-healing wound or chronic
would the point I make with this slide
is is that people when I tell people
that chronic wounds are infected they
that's not really accepted around the
wound community and yet it is a very
definition of infection by a very
respected article that's quoted often in
the literature we just haven't connected
the dots on that one so much as I want
you two to understand that that that
even the main stand on biofilm
literature is suggesting that if a wound
is chronic is failing to progress that
it is a sign of secondary sign of
infection at least okay that when I
start talking about acute and chronic
infections in the wound care community I
always hit questions by kidding chronic
wounds and that's two totally different
things we were talking about the chronic
will decry moon has this yellowish
material over the top of it and it has
the extra date you see the right there
so you know that is a chronic wound this
is a patient her name was Chris she came
in on 826 of 05 and I love this story
because my technicians taught me the
difference between echidna chronic wound
so I'm said I'm walking past this room
and here's his lady crying she's leaping
she's sobbing and what had happened was
she'd come into us she'd had this one
for almost a year she's in her late 30s
it's a venous leg ulcer and you know she
said you know you're our last hope you
know you're my last hope I've been
through everything so we get all our
anti biofilm stuff we were just
into it in 2004-2005 we we did all the
standard blinker stuff we wrapped it and
stuff and lo and behold three days later
on the twenty-ninth we have doubled the
size of the wound and that's why she
sobbing it's like oh no my wounds bigger
before I could ever talk to this this
young lady my technician who couldn't
see me he was he was facing her and said
hey Chris Chris don't worry about this
okay this this red one this new moon
that's going to heal in a couple weeks
okay we see that all the time that
that's caused by the dressings your
chronic wounds doing well and I'm
looking at them I'm going to get how do
you know that's God I mean what were you
getting this stuff and long behold two
weeks later I left this slide in that it
it was almost healed it's still through
the skin three weeks later it's
completely healed in the chronic wound
is there now why is that okay her her
venous insufficiency is the same where
that other glee wasn't he saw how deep
it was it was deep those down in
subcutaneous tissue you know it hadn't
been there as long but her host factors
were all the same in yet one wound heals
up in two weeks in the other one takes
two months what is the difference well
acute woods don't have bowel film and we
demonstrated that in that article in
2008 and chronic wounds do have bowel
bowel film maybe the reason why wounds
don't heal and we're going to show you
some more molecular evidence of that
this I just had to throw in at the last
minute I just found it about a month ago
and so the question we post G is is Ken
biofilm cause chronic with chronic
infections or can mouth will cause an
infection and what we find is that that
the European Society for infectious
disease very notable you know these are
people I've referenced I've talked to
I've spoke with it and I mean they're
they're the movers and shakers in
infectious disease and specifically in
chronic infectious disease like chronic
infections and what they say is
they're in there abstract is bow films
cause chronic infections so really the
cyanide mean that the debate is over i
mean the renowned scientists the best
clinicians the people that look at this
stuff say when you have a chronic
infection something that behaves like a
chronic infection biofilm is it's the
predicate cause for that and so that's
what we're going to talk about the rest
of the talk so I gave you the punchline
up front but you know this is this is
you know just trying to add more
emphasis from the literature Patel and
oppose oh how to Mayo Clinic back in two
thousand seven are who I credit for my
epiphany in this area of medical model
film and basically we classify cancer by
the term cancer so melanoma and
sarcomere radically different to treat
it different their diagnosis different
but their cells outside oppose control
to grow uncontrollably and so therefore
we call them cancers if we put all
medical biofilms into the category which
is what dr. Patel was doing in her talk
it's amazing okay so and the the thing
that I want you to take away from this
slide is that every discipline deals
with chronic infection so whether your
auntie your pulmonary whether you know
whatever you're dealing with you're
dealing with your specialty will have a
chronic infection associated with it and
all these different disciplines
independent of each other came to the
same way to treat these infections
basically ignore them treat them
episodic we with antibiotics when they
flare up in the patient complains enough
after a year two years or ten years when
the structure that the ball film is
attached to is degraded enough then you
strip the sinuses or you transplant the
lungs or you remove the metal or you
take out the catheter you take out the
stones you replace the heart valve and
for wounds we cut off the leg there so
we cut off body parts and I'm not here
to condemn how we treat this stuff I'm
just saying
that as we learn this stuff as you apply
your knowledge base to your area of
expertise when you can manage well film
adequately maybe you can stop cutting
off body parts maybe the way to treat
this is to cure the infection instead of
cut off body parts and that's what we're
looking for alright so I want to move
down into the molecular level in this
slide we've already we just looked at
both films real bathroom can cause
infections and now we're going to get
into some of the molecular tools that it
uses for those infections then we'll
look at diagnosis then we'll look at
treatment very rapidly okay the thing
that gives the community its power that
gives that its definition that gives us
its colony defenses is the extracellular
polymeric substance I was just I just
got back from japan yesterday I do we
gave multiple talks while we were there
and they are very strong in the use of
macrolides they use clarithromycin they
also use erythromycin and they do that
with almost all their chronic infections
and they do that not as the antibiotic
treating the bacterial cells but they
see that as a way to to break down
impair punch holes whatever you wanna
call to grade the extracellular matrix
and make their other treating agents
more successful a lot of this research
came by the University of Tokyo that's a
Tschida Kim people like that so they
have very strong molecular group mera
mera Socko that there's lots of names
there lots of good imaging lots of good
molecular work being done by the group's
over there so extra saying the polymeric
substance very important the next thing
is synergies we could not have beef
without the synergies in the different
stomachs of the cow this is the rumen
from some stomach and I don't know what
the bacteria are but the by-products of
the green are basically use the
breakdown products are used by
the red bacteria so you get i want you
to see some things that the bacteria
stayed in groups that they're swirled
like Neapolitan ice cream it's not a
homogenous mixture of the different
bacteria the other thing is is the the
byproducts that there's a metabolic
cooperation or synergy between both
bacterial biofilms that's critical and
it's an important and it's a relatively
unexplored area of chronic infections is
how the bacteria help one another low
abundance bacteria so in dental plaques
if you have lots of strep mutans so say
the green has struck mutants and you
throw in just a little bit of
porphyromonas gingivalis it changes the
biofilm from being a neutral bottom it
doesn't cause disease to one that causes
disease so it causes dysbiosis in that
biofilm in a mouse model so basically
we're talking about bacteria that are
1000 times less abundant then the rest
of the bacteria the rest of the biofilm
can still change the bowel film from
being a you know and something that the
host tolerates do something that causes
disease in the host the point there is
is you don't know what bacteria matter
when you look at a group of bacteria and
people say well then how you ever going
to treat it and we'll talk about those
principles in a second then finally
there's senescence and there's a type 3
secretory system type for secret or
system type 6 and each one of these
secret or systems like there's about 60
different effector proteins for
pseudomonas alone yersinia has about 30
35 different effector proteins so if you
look at this model over here that is a
cell that's a human cell and then the
little black dots that you see that's
your Simeon bacteria if the yersinia is
able to inject a small protein called
the OSP c3 and it's about 50 amino acids
it's a small little peptide it will go
in and it
what the a pop tonic pathways made with
a cascade system and it will prevent
this cell from dying so bacteria to be
successful to quote and kindred colonize
in my terminology cause vowel film they
must inject these small proteins into
the cell so this one protein will keep
this bacteria from apoptosis another
small molecule reorganize the
cytoskeleton another small molecule walk
cell division and and then another one
but block manufacturing so senescence is
just meaning that the hotel is
dysfunctional well the one care
community we always thought that that
the reason that the saloon dead cells
were senescent or dysfunctional was
because of oxidative stress or because
of proteolysis coriolis is from the mm
PS and now the pattern when you look
inside when you run the transcript codes
in the proteomes of these sell these
human cells that the senescence is is
more directly related to the activity in
a bacteria and not the inflammatory
environment that they're in now there's
no question inflammatory environment it
has an impact no question about that but
what we're saying is is for the ball
field to be successful it has to cause
these things and it does have the
molecular tools to do these things so we
think the primary motive senescence or
while in bed cells don't have show the
right host healing parameters and
everything else is directly dictated by
the biofilm itself you got to have an
animal model so i threw this in this
isn't really at the molecular level but
it's very important in it and drive one
point home so this comes out of
Northwestern this is Galliano and musto
and basically they have a rabbit model
where it's an impaired rabbit on the
blue robot film they'll seed all the
different sites that they take a box
here that they wound or they can leave
one openness of control and so now you
good you can test treating agents across
the time period what wrong with Madrid
aliana did here was he just showed that
if he debris did slough off alone Slough
that you can see that it would reform
quite quickly that Slough that they
pulled off was mainly human proteins
mainly plasma proteins there was also
bacterium there were also sugars which
they couldn't characterize but you know
the sugars are probably not
glycosaminoglycans are probably the
matrix material that we're talking about
so when you look at that when you run a
control biopsy versus a one that is as
bottle filled you get a p-value of point
zero zero zero one that means that
there's very low probability that this
impaired healing that we see with vile
film on the surface of the wound is due
to anything other than mechanisms of the
bowel film itself because the control
goes on to heal just just fine so bow
film doesn't care healing in an animal
model they didn't work out exactly how
that could be so here's Kim's work him
from Tokyo a sheet oh and the rest of
his group and basically what they did
was they reviewed the literature 300
different molecular articles of what's
happening inside the cell with these
bacteria no these are gonna thelios
cells but you know this translates and
basically what they found was in a third
of the experiments based on the
conditions the bacteria would penetrate
the cell reach the cell their words that
they would secrete variance factors
killed the cell cause necrosis cause a
pop ptosis and that was what most people
expected and that's what the scientists
thought was an infection and then in two
thirds of the articles that they
reviewed that didn't happen the bacteria
would cause cytoskeleton reorganization
it would block mitosis it would walk a
pop tonic pathways it would up-regulate
SOS survival pathways and so what Kim
and his group combat in there abstract
was this is a new way that there are new
paradigm
pathogenesis so what we're saying is is
basically this is a new way bacteria in
fact when we just shown you back at 99
con stratum was showing that the bomb
film was a different kind of bacterial
infection / acute infections but here's
side by side in this one panel on the
left you see that is an acute or
planktonic behavior that it would
correlate with an acute infection and
this would correlate with a chronic
infection and all the molecular data
that we get from chronic infections so
in just one panel they're showing the
difference between acute and chronic
which is pretty cool so let me divide
that up a little bit say it one more
time because it'll be my major point if
you get nothing else out of this lecture
and I really appreciate everybody's time
it's this planktonic bacteria as you see
here tend to cause acute infections and
they'll grow and a traditional culture
this this stuff grows in culture media
if it's the right culture media in the
right condition so you know ninety
percent of time ninety-five percent
excuse me five percent of time ten
percent of time most of our common bugs
will grow anaerobes not so much and
fastidious the mycobacterium Xand things
that take too long but the clinical
culture isn't geared towards those
bacteria and we find a lot of them in
the wood so but at least culture has a
chancer Bob film phenotype bacteria do
not go there viable but not culturable
that's if you google that you'll find
tons of articles on that they cost
eighty percent of the infections in
humans right now that was from an NIH
meeting it they're the cause of chronic
wounds and that comes out of that
European infectious disease that
my guidelines that we talked about they
will not grow in traditional cultures
and biofilms are radically different
phenotypically from planktonic bacteria
so they behave differently when we try
to put them in clinical culture
conditions so just know that my tide
bacteria associated with acute
infections and they that you can culture
will will let you down a lot but not
near as much as biofilm and in chronic
infections probably microbial situation
cultures are wholly inadequate for
diagnosing those and that's why we're
going to go into a different paradigm
different actor most of wound care is
done trial and error the nurses back in
two thousand four and five when they
would walk in the room and we were
teaching that bullying care they would
ask me why did you put that on there and
why are you switching to this and in the
quick answer is I don't know I tried
iodine Nyota zorg and now i'm switching
the hydro fair blue because the others
work didn't work okay it's trial and
error and and you know you tried to
guess by the smell or this or that but
the one thing that we care physicians
quickly realize is that cultures don't
matter the there's several rcts that
show that if you get a clinical culture
and you treat what the clinical culture
shows you don't get any better outcomes
so now what we're what we're saying is
is we need a different tool to diagnose
so let's look at that diagnostic tools
that are available [ __ ] I came up with
the idea of a pure culture and basically
what he is his paradigm back in eighteen
sixty over a hundred years ago 150 years
ago is that that one bacteria causes an
infection well we know that's not true
in chronic infections there
polymicrobial now they're less diverse
as you get into a lung like cystic
fibrosis there's less diversity than a
wound when you get too many chronic
meningitis or chronic prostatitis
there's less diversity that
the long expect at the end of the day
bow films they like diversity they're
more successful than more diverse and
that's been proven in lots of different
chronic infections so his genius lee and
his ability to bring order out of chaos
but his way he brought warner was he
just neglected all this different
bacteria and guess what we're not very
good at managing chronic infections it
set us back for over 100 years because
of that one promise that we laid out it
that it had to be one organism so if you
can broaden your perspective of human
infectious disease to include
polymicrobial infections' infections
where their synergies between the
bacteria where there's community
behavior while that opens up a lot of
possibilities so pure culture here's the
limitations of your culture you get 24
hours you played out your initial sample
you get 24 hours and then the clinician
the technician goes in and he's going to
pick a colony so we put this plate up
here to show you that in this one plate
these are lots of different morphologies
of the colony and guess what the
technician really quickly learns it's
what staff looks like he quickly learns
she quickly learns what the Pseudomonas
looks like and guess what when they have
two or three or four different colonies
morphologies to pick from they're going
to pick quote the pathogen close quote
well that's a self-fulfilling prophecy
it's the pathogen because that's when
you pick and that's a huge bias and pure
cultures the other thing is is there's
my tonic concept in cultures this is the
10 to the 5th long logarithmic growth
phase dropping a disk to see what about
antibiotic resistance those things don't
hold up in involve a model and then the
the biggest
the problem with peer culture is when
you subplate this the next plate you're
going to bring this one colony across
well it's still polymicrobial but what
they found was if you grow it on this
thick liquid called auger well very
quickly that the things that grow best
will out-compete any other quote
contaminants unquote that are in in that
sample the earning that colony you moved
over and so the the planktonic growing
behavior causes competition and survival
of the fittest and so the thing that
grows best is what gets reported out to
you so you can see that it takes
polymicrobial infections' can you never
adequately be diagnosed my pure culture
here's the other thing is there's a
reality to culturing when you do swabs
you're getting the top bacteria not the
bacteria by the by the surface of the
moon the other thing is is it's not
handled the way the American Society of
microbiology says it should be handled
you know that when you transport it that
this was stuff that was laid out in the
late afternoon and the hot Sun where it
gets 200 degrees in lubbock texas and
who knows how long it's out there so
there's a high probability of error from
the very start just because of the
practicalities of getting it to the lab
and getting it going now pcr isn't
without bias and i understand that we're
going to have a lot of molecular people
on here so i'm not really dealing i'm a
clinician so anything that i tell you
about pcr and sequencing you know you
guys are the most of y'all are better at
that than I am so I'm just going to go
some basic concepts on this so the
problem with the PCR is very accurate it
gets us down the low copy number so if
there's very few of an organism there we
could we can say plus minus is it there
and it can be absolutely
a quantitative in an absolute sense if
you run the standards on your set on
that same plate of 100 organisms and a
thousand and ten thousand not getting
those standards are difficult but if you
have them you can you know get fairly
close to the absolute number of copies
of that specific bug that that that
you're looking for the downside of PCR
is there are primer biases and the
biggest thing is is you have to have a
specific primer that doesn't cross react
with anything else for each organism
that you want to identify when we've
already identified over 2,000 microbes
and links and the from the previous
stuff we said we can't say what's the
pathogen and what's not the passage of
what synergies matter and what don't at
this time so you know you can't get
there with pcr p chars are really good
for very quickly half day turnaround
that tells me if there's nurse if
there's pseudomonas if there's certain
antibiotic resistance genes and so you
know I can look to 16 things really
quick and say okay all my resist all my
major things that I need to know about
are not there basically hopefully
excluding them or if they are there I
can start treating immediately my MRSA
or mine pseudomonas or whatever so
that's that's the power of pcr it can
tell us the bacterial load in an
absolute sense how much bacteria is
there and it can rule out all that all
the big time common pathogens it will
sometimes see it won't sequencing
there's multiple platforms now the
pyrosequencing is kind of being phased
out the 454 people look to the p8 the
the Ion Torrent proton torrent or the my
seek IC buttcrack miles coming so the
platforms are changing and they all have
different technologies and i'm not going
to go into those because i don't know
well enough but all of them put out a
gate the eighth the the base sequence on
what you're looking at now everybody's
looked at 16 s up to this time it's a
the fingerprint gene to tell you what
species and even sometimes what strain
of bacteria you're looking at if you get
enough reads long enough reads uh but
but now with the with the advent of the
the cheaper sequencing methods it's
evolving more toward back to
metagenomics because it's cheaper it's
almost as fast and it can give you
information now to the strain level but
it also gives you the resistance factors
and the various factors that are there
so it's much more complete my thing is
it's sequencing far outpaces is far more
comprehensive than culturing so it's
ready for prime time so 16s analysis
hundred bucks tells you all your fungus
all your bacteria most of your Archaia
you know that is that's really quality
and it tells you going to the button so
touch your major minor and constituents
a bit of what you're treating so
sequencing offers a lot so DNA
sequencing I'm going to go real quick
over this finds all the microbial DNA is
there compares it to known sequences
within a database and it tells you who's
there and a relative abundance of which
microbe is there so that's our hope for
change can we change from the archaic
culture 150 year old mechanism and go to
the more computerized computer based
methods that's hard for clinicians I
didn't realize it would be so hard
because and the biggest impediment is
you get a lot of information but I think
we can help you sort that out here's why
it becomes important and Rhodes did a
guy in our office he's a molecular
pathologists now not too many in the
country but then did 50 consecutive
patients that came into the office and
if you compare if you use culture as the
gold standard we the university
laboratory was able to identify
92 different bacteria in those 50
patients however over fifty percent of
the time what they identified were
things at weren't or in the original
culture or were less than 1% of the
original culture over seventeen percent
of time what was between one and ten
percent so basically anything that was
ten percent or less you would expect the
culture not to find but yet over again
fifty-three percent of the time that's
what the culture reported so it was
amplifying minor things and let that
blew me away I really thought that a
culture would go in and if it was eighty
percent sumo sandwich obesity moments I
just thought it would but we had
multiple cultures where there was a
dominant orgasm eighty ninety percent
and here was reported out staph aureus
which was there one percent so that was
an eye-opener for me but the biggest
reason to switch to molecular is if you
consider molecular it's a gold standard
not counting anaerobic bacteria because
we could do an elongate cultures without
552 different species we doubled the
these are dominant important species in
the dark dark color down here and it's
double what the culture found so
basically and that what the take-home
message there is as cultures are only
showing about twenty percent of the
microorganisms that are present in a
chronic wound and that's why they are so
that's why clinically cultures have not
helped us in healing chronic wounds I
just want to throw this up here real
quick we submitted this last month just
a couple weeks ago to wound repair and
regeneration and basically this helps us
empirically we looked at about 3,000
wounds to 2963 and what we found was
sixty-three percent of time there was a
staff species there were and the red
number is the number of species there's
about 20 different staff species a
quarter of all staff with staph aureus
which means 75
was quite made herself again when you're
in a permissive environment of the world
there are no commensal mechanism so
those great news desperate really
halogens they were active as pathogens
they were propagating and causing harm
Courtney bacterium was in thirty-six
percent of our wounds and number of
different species but again a commensal
traditionally but in a non commensal
environment we have to take it into
account when we're doing our empirical
therapy pseudomonas came in at about
twenty-five percent of wood so in about
a quarter wounds but when it was present
they had much more representations with
relative abundance was actually greater
than most staff so even though it's in
third well close to a third the number
of loans it has a higher relative
abundance value than the staff and then
you see that it quickly drops off to
twelve percent by the time we're down
here to prep Nutella you know it one in
ten have that so basically that the
point here is wounds are highly highly
polymicrobial you can expect some sort
of staff and ones but only about twenty
to thirty percent of time is it the main
thing you're going to see lots of
commensals like programa bacteria and
the Kearney bacterium and stuff and then
the biggest thing that I wanted to show
you here was that in this top 10 4 of
these our anti robes so in robes are are
huge and their way unreported way under
appreciated in chronic wounds and so
that when you're dealing with your
empiric treatment of chronic wounds you
have to consider anaerobic coverage
alright so now we're going to get to
treatment we got about 10 minutes to get
through the rest of this so bear with me
when you go to one care conferences what
they do is a way over think how to
manage a wound okay they try to use
their head and
should use the brush to manage their
powerful when you treat your toilet when
you treat your teeth your tongue your
countertop you are managing about them
and what you know more than anything
else is you debris and the we need the
nurse that taught me my wouldn't care
she said the slough the yellow stuff
that's on the surface of the one that's
like a bunny in the garden you take that
off it's going to come right back you
saw golly ELMO slide it comes back
within 24 hours so my point is is that
Slough is not a bunny in the garden that
is a chronic infection on the surface of
the wound and it changes its texture and
it changes quality it changes actionaid
and tenderness based on how well you
suppress the bow from its present that's
producing that inflammation producing
that extra day and in company
incorporating that that plasma protein
in its biofilm matrix we looked at the
mouth of matrix to say you know if we
can't take it off if it's just going to
come right back you know how do we
manage that how we ever going to defeat
meanwhile film so we went to CBE and
what we found was that this that if you
destroy disrupt a pseudomonas original
film that within 24 hours its antibiotic
tolerance redevelops if we do the same
thing in a pig excellent bottle it takes
about three to four days for that window
to close for that allows them to
reestablish itself on that piece of pig
skin that we use if you use a burn mouse
model in a live mouse it takes about
four days for the bottom to become
tolerant of bleach and gentamicin and
then if we look at a human we find the
same thing at day 21 of the patients had
closed the window the mouth on that
reformed it was tolerant to antibiotics
but by three days all three patients
that have a pseudomonas ball film
the window had clothes so basically what
we found is when you just rub that
yellowish Slough on the surface of the
moon when it's forced to reconstitute
itself it's sensitive to treating agents
and that's about a 32 Ford a window
missa patient sent to us by a plastic
surgeon and she said look this patient
will do a donor site for a skin graft
this is ready for a skin graft I think
if you know then she said the edges are
healing and they are they're feathering
in and and the colors generally yellow I
generally read but you do see patches of
yellow and basically we were able to
probably film an intact film of plasma
with embedded bacteria off the surface
in this wound and so the management of
the surface is critical and you got to
have frequent agreement the other
question I get is what about necrotic
tissue what about dead tissue that's on
the surface alone this is pyoderma so
there's deep necrosis in this but when
we when we boxing these areas of the
process yeah there's tissue in there but
there's organized bottom structures and
then after we debride frequently and we
do our model film-based won't care we
can get to what we're after this is this
is the same leg about six months later
and you see the bumpy texture and that's
the granular nature the means I showed
this slide is so many people talk to me
about a necrotic granulation tissue I've
gotten so many referrals and I'm saying
if something's necrotic it's not great
it's not granulation tissue granulation
tissue needs to look like this with
those bumps with that color when it
looks like this it's not granulating
it's something else so let me talk about
my general principles about the basement
care real quickly and knowing that you
know this is a work in progress and some
of the things that I'm going to tell you
we may not blink two or three years from
now but right now this works it works
really good so we'll talk about it
so Bob Donbass won't care is doing
multiple concurrent dynamic strategies
and basically the FDA hits this okay so
when we talk about treatment strategies
and systems for chronic lives what's
mandated by regulatory agencies is is
that you try one thing so you can prove
that it worked or not if it had the
efficacy and then you try the next thing
and then you try the next day and that
sequential stuff doesn't work for above
them because it has multiple species of
bacteria that can reorganize around the
any of its member so if you knock out
twenty percent of its members it
reorganizes andrey establishes itself
without that contingent so you have to
do multiple different things at the same
time and then you have to change when
the biofilm change this is a God's
that's sewn on to a chronic an opening
that's made in them house and if you
don't put something like this on it
it'll heal up in two to three days but
if you put this gauze on there it will
last for months and when I saw that I
said well it's not the cause it's
keeping that open it's a slime that's
keeping it open so my point on this is
we choose dressings that don't have they
don't allow about them to attach to it
and deform it within it because it's
going to seed all those follow all those
diffusible molecules back on the woman
and keep it from healing so it's about
them that causes that so the multiple
strategies we use is number one
debridement that's when we talked about
use of the brush that's what you do on
your teeth twice a day and you're under
that for the rest of your life so don't
get don't get tired of being aggressive
with debridement you selectively mouth
sides and that silver I dimethyl going
by selectively but I mean it it kills
the bacteria but it doesn't kill whole
cells we use anti bowel film dressings
we don't want Wow film to to form on our
dressings and seed material back onto
the wound
and we use antibiotics we don't shy away
from them we use some personalized and
we use a long them strong but the way to
use strong antibiotics is to apply
topically so once we get our diagnostic
back we formulate a specific
individualized gel for the that microbes
it around the wound and we apply that
and usually 11 gel will follow that
wound and tell its completion usually
something else doesn't emerge but
occasionally it does and so we end up
changing the the recoloring and changing
the gel about 1.3 times ever in that
3001 that we talked about so that's my
film based workout let's talk about how
it works this is Alan Alan showed up
he's a concrete worker he's about 40
years only showed up at ER with a foot
full of pus and so they took him to the
operating room and the surgeon found
that he had osteomyelitis they woke him
up in the recovery room and said hey
Alan which is not his name look you're
gonna you're gonna need a major limb
amputation we got to cut your leg off
below the knee well he used construction
language concrete worker language I'm
the surgeon and said no I don't think so
so he left AMA he got back to the room
but he left they have made that day and
came over charoen on 7 29 09 on 7 30 09
I might mention that surgeon called me
and he'd already learned that
construction language and he told me in
construction language that Alan's death
was on my head and I said you know you
know and I knew and personally and I
said no it's not going to happen because
he we know about film we know what
causes that yellow stuff we know what
causes that that necrotic tissue we're
going to diagnose it we're going to
treat it with multiple concurrent
strategies were going to change what we
need to and and this is going to heal
okay and so he didn't leave me but a
month later it looks a lot better uh two
months later eight weeks later we said
it was healed not that he
go back to work and 12 weeks later we
let him go back to work I have a bunch
of these you know and it should not
surprise it you know it's really cool
when you see it but it shouldn't
surprise us as one care providers if
we're saying that that the senescence
the slow healing that we see in a
chronic wound is directly related to the
biofilm by by resolving that bond film
we should resolve that barrier and it
should heal like an acute loop so
basically we had a bunch of Allens in
this group here and if you treat with
standard of care the trial and error
that we talked about you feel about
fifty percent of wounds in six months if
you go to the molecular diagnostics with
the customers topical antibiotics you
heal about 90% once in six months and
that makes sense because you know if
Malcolm is an important barrier then
suppressing that should allow that
healing to take place alright so that's
the biofilm surprise there's two ways
that bacteria in fact so if you'll take
that home planktonic bacteria cause
acute infections biofilm phenotype
bacteria cause chronic infections you
have the ability to diagnose and to
treat personalized specifically the word
but if you take this away bow film is
why chronic wounds behave chronically
that the duration the non-healing the
exudate etc so that's the mouth I'm
surprised it is an important barrier
it's a bunny it's not a money in the
garden it's like a bunny we've never
ever met before and thank you for your
time so now we'll open it up to
questions well thank you dr. Walcott for
that very informative presentation it's
Kuhn a time now and if any of you have
any questions you'd like to ask dr.
Walcott please sniffing now you can do
so by clicking on the green Q&A button
the lower left of the presentation
window and type in your question or
comment and clicking on sinned let's
wait a little while to see if anyone in
the audience would like to ask a
question
if there are no questions I'd like to
win skin thank dr. Walcott and dr.
Walcott or any closing statements you'd
like to make before we in the broadcast
well again I didn't get feedback from
the individual faces but i hope this
clicked and I hope people will take this
on us as research it as an area of
interest for them if they if they want
to see this again or if they want any
more material they can email me and i
think that's on the presentation
material someplace i do respond to
emails and again we want to catalyze any
research any interest that we can in any
field that people would have an interest
in volatile and i'll turn a cold new
bomb well thanks again dr. well god and
a special thanks to her audience for
joint is finally I'd like to thank our
sponsor roche diagnostics for making
this presentation possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari 2016 lab roots
will send you an email alerting to you
when it's available on demand and that
will also be posted on Latin roots calm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
aren't able to join the presentation
today thanks again for joining us and
participating in today's broadcast until
next time thanks and see you later